WELL, BUTCH, THE SAME
WIN IN NEW JERSEY, A 3-2 VICTORY
DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF JUMP IN
D
STEPAN.
A CHANCE THERE.
THEY SCORE.
OH, BOY.
THE HURRICANES WITH A C THE MOV
GET IT UP A YOU CAN TELL DOBSON
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED WITH
HIMSELF THERE AS THEAST AHO.
BARZAL I IER AGAINST THE
PREDATORS AND EVER SINCE THEN
HE'S BEEN GREAT SO LET'S
BROCK NELSON.
1-0 HURRICANES EARLY AT UBS
ARENA.
EL THE WAY THESE GUYS
eANG.
SVECHNIKOV INSIDE OF THE
PULOCK NELSON.
>> GOOD COVER THERE BY NELSON ON
THAT YOU CAN'T TELL
CONCLUSIVELY FROM
ACTIVE  MATT MARTIN DOES THE
SMART THING.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE KNEW
MEMORABLE MOMENT?
>> WELL, YOU
BEHIND THE NET AND SLAVIN BELLO
OF COURSE, GET IT TOWARDS END
AND KOIVULA HAS AN OP WHAT HAPP
AND STUTTER STEPPING POLAK GUESS
AR
SHOT, TOO, SIX OAT HIS
EXPERIENCE WAS TODAY AND I KNOW
THAT YOU'VE BEEN VERER HAD WHOL
LOT BACK THERE.
>> Al: HURRICANES ARE GOING TO
GET ONE.
IT'S PUCK N.SIMPLE
PLAY AND DUMPS IT BEHIND
TIGHTER.
>> JIGS, I WISH WE HAD MORET TO.
GET THE FEET MOVINGVE HELPED AN
HAVE MADE THINGS HAD A LITTLE
EASIER.EUTRAL ZONE
WILL MAKE IT 4-2 VERYER.
STAAL, AGAIN, SUCH A GOOD
DEFENSIVE PLAYER.
GETS IT OUT IN THE BLUE LINE AN?
AND BRENDAN SMITH SAYS, YES, I